welcome to this video playing drama da
told me da just about all I have some I
don't know yeah I think I had a very
stupid time loss against him recently
way just played nothing moves the whole
game and one on time I think this is the
correct recollection of that okay so
he's playing some modern defense see
going for easier he's going for the for
the hippo hmm yeah if I push at five is
this some is this something or if I if I
if I've probably not f5 is very early
not sure if this is well-timed okay I'm
going to push it anyway he cannot he
cannot castle at least okay he's playing
very quickly
yeah the position is of course a little
bit it looks a little bit uncoordinated
for black but I don't think it is so bad
let's think about it I would like to
take on f5 with the night so maybe I
need to prepare it like that night h4
okay he wants Knight takes on g4 I can
go to h4 anyway Queen a5 threatening
mate 1 f7
yeah this looks like a train wreck
really would be and I would be surprised
if this is this is any good for black
but maybe maybe you can can play that
okay I'm taking him now G for green G 3
looks looks very bad with the g7 g7
hanging I mean very bad this is putting
it mildly think of winning yeah okay so
if I take it Bishop takes takes here
Queen age six and curtains or not oh
it's there a quicker win your d5 as
sorts so quite nice but okay let's let's
give the check Bishop age six
yeah there's this queen g4 yeah possibly
we're just not helping him I can just
take and the bishop is also hanging
which is quite something you take it
okay so rook f3 g3 he will put the
bishop on g6 maybe this is this is a bit
better
having the rook on the F fireless is a
bit bit better
check yeah he's a ticking deform I can
take him Jim check check check check
yeah check first thing later okay so I'm
covering d4 I'm covering d1 you can give
a check here I can give a chick on check
on a1 then you can give a check here hmm
isn't there a simple way to win this
check there is right I can win the rook
check let's just do that
check black resigned yeah I don't know I
mean okay this is not a really great
opening for black anyway but I don't
know exactly where went down lf5 was was
very crude but I don't know if he should
defend as he did I was actually thinking
he should take and play g5 I wasn't sure
about this position I mean by classical
standards blacks position is terrible
but maybe it's not that bad
I don't know but this this looks
difficult the computer is on plus 2
which tells you something
it gives d5 now yeah and this is also
plus 2 ok and night h4 s plus 3 and this
is plus 5 yeah yeah it's it's a disaster
cannot play like that here yeah yeah
yeah I missed the checkmate I'm not
surprised by that can't shake yeah I
could can I repeat at once
oh yeah rookie have 7 is checkmate yeah
okay that was stupid yeah okay but rook
is the rook and I rather take the rook
and win and then playing for checkmate
that maybe it's not there yeah okay
quick win thanks for watching